tenemos aquí una función ligeramente
complicada es una función definida por
partes y como podemos observar aquí
básicamente lo que tenemos son puras
líneas lo que hay aquí en medio de todos
estos puntos decimales y signos menos lo
que tenemos es una línea recta y bueno
la función f se define como esta línea
en este intervalo de x como esta otra
línea en este intervalo y finalmente
como esta línea en este intervalo pero
bueno lo que queremos hacer en este
vídeo es graficar esta función
así es que pone una pausa el vídeo e
intenta graficar la por tu cuenta
listo bueno vamos a empezar por graficar
esta parte de la función fx en el
intervalo de menos 10 a menos 2 está
definida como menos 0.25 x
y 4.75 lo cual significa que es una
línea entonces para graficar este pedazo
de la función lo único que necesitamos
hacer es graficar los puntos finales y
unirlos y eso es justo lo que vamos a
hacer así es que pues cuánto vale la
función en los extremos de este
intervalo esto lo vamos a hacer por acá
cuando x es igual a menos 10 la función
vale menos 0.125 x menos 10 o sea la x +
4.75 menos x menos nos da más y punto
125 por 10 es 1.25 y eso más 4.75 es
igual a 6 entonces cuando x vale menos
10 la función vale 6 así es que tenemos
el punto menos 10 coma
aunque hay ponemos por aquí un punto que
tal vez de vídeo ser este otro azul pero
bueno estamos dibujando lo así porque
como aquí tenemos un menor o igual eso
significa que también estamos incluyendo
al menos 10 y después de eso nos damos
hasta el -2 y en menos 2 la función vale
menos 0.125 x menos 2 + 4.75 lo cual es
igual a ver - x menos dos damas 0.125
por 2 es 0.25 y eso más 4.75 es 5 y en
estos momentos tal vez queramos poner el
punto menos 2,5 así
recuerda que en este intervalo no
estamos incluyendo al menos dos porque
tenemos un menor estricto aunque tenemos
a todos los puntos mayores o iguales a
menos 10 que estén a la izquierda de
menos 2 pero este intervalo no incluye
al menos 2 al si es que todavía no
podemos asegurar que la función evaluada
en menos 2 sea 5 aunque hay porque esta
parte de la función todavía no está
definiendo cuánto vale efe de menos 2
pero lo que sí sabemos es que conforme x
se acerca a menos 2 f x se acerca cada
vez más a 5 entonces lo que hacemos es
poner un círculo abierto sin relleno por
aquí y bueno esto es una línea recta
entonces ponemos por aquí
y listo bueno ahora vamos con la
siguiente parte de esta función esto de
aquí define cuánto vale la función entre
-2 y menos 1 y en este intervalo la
función vale x + 7 aunque hay entonces
en este extremo efe de menos 2 es menos
2 + 7 o sea 5 así es que ponemos menos
2,5 y bueno esto es una coincidencia muy
agradable resulta que esta función si
vale 5 en el menos dos y luego cuando x
vale menos 1 f x es menos 17 o sea 6 y
hay que recordar que como aquí tenemos
un menor estricto entonces esta parte de
la función no incluye al valor de menos
1 así es que tenemos menos 1,6 pero
tenemos que dejar el círculo abierto sin
relleno ok
porque conforme x se acerca a menos 1
x se va a acercar a menos 17 aunque se
va a acercar cada vez más a 6
vamos con el último intervalo cuando x
es igual a menos 1 tenemos menos por
menos 1 eso es más o sea que tenemos 12
con seamos más 5411 a vos
eso es 66 onceavos que es 6 si es que
podemos ir al menos 16 y podemos
rellenar este círculo y luego cuando x
es igual a 10 tenemos menos 12 onceavos
por 10 eso es menos 120 entre 11 más 54
onceavos y esto es igual a ver a cuánto
es igual menos 120 más 54 eso es menos
66 cierto bueno y entonces esto de aquí
es menos 6 y entonces cuando
x es igual a 10 nuestra función es igual
a menos 6 y unimos estos dos de aquí
y esta función resulta que no tiene
saltos no siempre nos pasa eso pero
bueno ya terminemos de graficar esta
función que es una función definida por
partes